in spite of their obvious increased
physical strength compared to women men
are more vulnerable biologically than
women are the vulnerability begins in
the womb far fewer male embryos make it
to delivery compared with females even
at birth boys are developmentally behind
their sisters and are prey to
developmental disabilities and
respiratory problems among others in the
immediate weeks in the weeks immediately
after birth this vulnerability continues
during the course of their life one of
the most important health problems of
men is the early onset of coronary
artery disease which begins to be
symptomatic and many men in the mid 30s
and those men who have coronary disease
are usually dead before the age of 65 I
think this is one of the most compelling
health problems that men face and
something on which we should really be
concentrating
velop mental disabilities are four to
six times more frequent in males than in
females we don't really know why this is
correct
but a very interesting theory has
developed in which it was pointed out by
some neonatal experts that the brains of
boys are larger than those of their
sisters and at the same time their
metabolic rate is lower so that the
demands of the bigger brain are really
not met as efficiently by the low
metabolic rate which doesn't deliver
enough oxygen and blood to the brain as
is the case with their sisters who have
smaller and probably more efficient
systems of providing the brain with
blood and oxygen
one of the most vulnerable periods for
men or males is during adolescence there
is a lag time in the development of the
systems in the brain that have to do
with risk assessment and judgment at the
same time the surge of testosterone
makes them prone to idealistic impulsive
and risk-taking behavior so that suicide
and violent death is far more common in
the male adolescent than it is in the
female adolescent we really capitalize
on this sadly by sending eighteen year
olds to war a very smart man said to me
who is in the military that if you ask
an 18 year old to take a well-defended
object objective he'll say when if you
ask a 30 year old to take the same
objective he'll say how and if you ask a
40 year old man he'll say why
I think there are definite steps we
should be taking and taking immediately
to ensure better and longer lives for
men in the first place we should stop
regarding them as the quote stronger
unquote sex they are biologically much
less Hardy in many ways than our women
in particular we should be concentrating
in my opinion on the early onset of
coronary disease which takes such a
terrible toll of men and I think the
American Heart Association should have a
program called go blue for men the way
it does go red for women
I think heart disease and it's early and
devastating onset in men is one of the
most important health problems that we
face